a fundamental truth that half the
country insists we all deny namely that
babies are people babies are people more
obvious even than that men are not women
and yet half of our country denies this
fact in the United States today if you
disturb the egg of a bald eagle you will
face a quarter million dollar fine and
two years in federal prison if you serve
foie gras one of my favorite dishes
fatty goose liver if you serve that in a
New York restaurant you will be fined
$2,000
the City Council strongly considered
adding a jail sentence for serving that
delicacy because foie gras is considered
animal cruelty if you ask your waitress
for a plastic straw in Santa Barbara
that server could be forced to pay
$1,000 and served six months in jail
because of the off chance that your
plastic straw could end up in a landfill
that then ends up in the ocean then then
ends up in the nose of a tortoise a
tortoise which could be served on the
menu of that very same restaurant in
suit disturb the egg of an eagle you
will wind up bankrupt and in the clink
but kill a human baby at just about any
stage of development just about anywhere
in this country and you will be
celebrated as a brave defender of
freedom you can't sip from a plastic
straw because a South Pacific
tortoise might inhale it but you can
kill a baby with arms and legs and eyes
and hands a baby with a heart and a face
almost anywhere in the u.s. up until the
point of birth and if the governor of
Virginia is to be believed you can kill
the baby even after birth most Americans
think that this is insane it was a
recent survey from the Harvard Center
for American Political Studies in Harris
Poll found that most Americans 70
percent believe that abortion should
only be permitted in the first trimester
or in cases of rape and incest a
whopping ninety four percent of
Americans believe there should be some
restrictions on abortion unfortunately
the remaining six percent seemed to
comprise every leftist politician and
activist in mainstream media mouthpiece
in the country the vast majority of
Americans want restrictions on abortion
and the left is clamoring for abortion
on demand without apology funded by your
taxpayer dollars how does the left force
their unpopular abortion policies down
everybody's throats while they convince
you that the issue is very complicated
they convince you that men half the
population cannot have an opinion on the
subject never mind that women are more
likely to identify as pro-life than men
are and that's according to Democratic
pollster Selinda Lake never mind that
the same leftists who tell us that men
can't have an opinion on abortion are
also the leftists who tell us that men
can actually have abortions I am looking
at you who Leon Castro they're the same
leftists who tell us that men really are
women and women are really men but the
men anyway can't have an opinion on
abortion they won't do anything stupid -
Annie depth to prevent you from
recognizing that babies are people